alors est-ce que par local riani là s'il
vous plaît pour thierry ardisson
alors
bonjour thierry ardisson est ce que par
local ya hélas au nom
paulo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
oui
[Musique]
oh
alors
très beau c'est encore plus beau
qu'avant
c'est devenu magnifique bague je vais
après les pv des lumières respecter
bougies peut-être à huy
[Musique]
nous
m
[Musique]
c'est comment cette décoration du balad
paulo spéciale on a fait comme si comme
s'il avait bien fait
[Musique]
on a cédé père comme constructive et
nous lancer dans les retraites reste du
canada je fais rennais on remarque la
table et il avait bien trop nombreux
types tous qu'il était saoul comme un
rideau à akwa et cela devient théâtre
ici et comme un temps que je vis ici
mais si ça fait dix ans déjà
c'était quoi ce lieu avant avance et un
entrepôt frigorifique et donc il est à
l'époque de là à l'époque de la guerre
j'ai pas que ce serait pour mettre un
peu les règles d'hygiène simples comme
la
jccd depuis qui a arrangé ça fait tout
était déplacé là bas et les trains
arrivés il y avait d'ailleurs même les
wagons qui arrivaient directement ici
dans la
meubles il y avait déjà des rats et même
dans les couloirs ouais donc la
marchandise arrive et soudée sur des
petits bars wagon directement ici c'est
pour ça que les les les appartements
sont en face pas des appartements mais
les lieux sont assez fermé ça sert mais
oui si chacun sait pas c'est que quand
ils gardaient l'immeuble de l'extérieur
ça fait comme un brouillard épais de
plusieurs à descendre à 4
manettes les principaux en plus parce
que quand on est chez toi et qu'on
regarde par la fenêtre on va voir
maintenant je vais t'ouvrir
ouais c'est étonnant ce convoi par la
fenêtre parce que le seul coup c'est une
complètement une autre
cette ambiance est très bon quand même
les goûts pour les chantiers ça qui est
beau c'est le but maintenant c'est le
maroc et le personnel et tous les futurs
un peu des parts et des droits en train
de construire la nouvelle station de
métro qui s'appelle météo
ça qui donne un côté un peu new york
j'aime bien parce qu'à ses côtés peu et
new york
mais ça c'est la dernière partie des
décors que j'ai fait cette espèce d'épée
qui loge d'opéra là
c'est drôle avec une erreur en pl
ambitieux
il a dit - c'est quoi cette locomotive
qui est ici à l'hadopi et ça c'est une
artiste qui est mon voisin qui s'appelle
jamais chef jean-michel poids qui lui un
fan de son travail d'artiste c'était mon
travail conceptuel et pendant cinq ans
il a fait toutes les démarches d'aller
en pologne pour récupérer une locomotive
qui est servi je cois pendant la guerre
tu vas pour
expliquez bien tu vas tout ce qui va
avec a
baissé plus que rigole
à la
locomotive c'est toi là
j'ai hâte de l'avoir fait
s'il a mené de pologne c'est ça
et c'est inégaux motif qu'ils savaient
transporter les gens dans les camps que
ça c'est une locomotive de guerre
et
alité en pologne
sexualisé un truc le plus impressionnant
c'est l'odeur oui
c'est vrai que en fait il ya cette
scénographie il voulait centrer en
premier
le visiteur lui quand le lieu est ouvert
au grand public
commence par sentir l'odeur c'est
l'odeur et la deuxième chose c'est que
l'endroit étant relativement exigu par
rapport à l'objet on est impressionné
par la dimension de l'objet c'est à dire
qu'on ne comprend que si on avait
cinquante mètres de recul on serait
beaucoup moins impressionnée par que là
on voit la locomotive comme devait
l'avoir les gens qu'on mettait dans le
trap alors ce qui est troublant aussi
dense sur cet objet c'est que elle a été
construit en économie de guerre
c'est à dire qu'elle a été étudié pour
couper moins cher possible être la plus
efficace possible
avec la logique de l'industrie allemande
de l'époque
et ils ont créé cette espèce de monstre
c'est un monstre ce qu'on retient c'est
en quelques sortes un morceau d'obus
voilà alors les les roues ont été
peintes
les bandeaux blancs des roues sont
peints avec de la peinture fluorescente
et c'était important pour moi parce que
c'est parti du de la réflexion sur
l'objet sur l'objet de l'histoire qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire avec un objet
d'histoire
comment faire de cet objet une oeuvre
d'art par une intervention éphémère
puisque la fluorescence disparaît qu'il
n'en reste pas de trace et par son
déplacement
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu